اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه
التحليليه لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع
غزه نستضيف المحلل العسكري اللواء فايز
الدويري كما تكون معنا ايضا سلام خضر على
الخارطه التفاعليه سلام جباليه هي العنوان
الابرز اليوم في كل الاشتباكات الدائره
على مختلف ما يجري ولكن جبالي الابرز حتى
الان بالضبط والمنطقه الشماليه عادت
واشتعلت الى حد بعيد وكاننا عدنا الى
الاسابيع الاولى من العمليه البريه اذا شم
ال قطاع غزه يشهد تركزا عاليا للعمليات
العسكريه وقتال مباشرا بين القوات
الاسرائيليه وبين كتائب المقاومه عند اكثر
من نقطه البدايه ستكون من جباليا جباليا
هي منتق الاشتباك الاعنف حاليا كتائب
القسام تقول انها تخوض اشتباكات مباشره
ومن مسافات قريبه وا استخدمت تعبير
اشتباكات بالاسلحه الخفيفه هذا يعني ان
المسافات بين قوات الاحتلال وبين كتائب
المقاومه والمقاومين قريبه جدا وفي جباليا
ايضا رصد قبل بضعه دقائق ايضا تحليق
للطائرات المقاتله ونفذت عده غارات من غير
المعلوم اين تركزت هذه الغارات ولكن بحسب
ما سمعنا ونسمع من اللواء الدويري ان
القوات الاسرائيليه تعمد الى استخدام اما
المدفعيه او الطائرات لاستهداف
لاستهداف بعض المناطق بحالتين اما عند
تعرضها لهجوم شديد لدفع المقاومين الى
التراجع او لتامين انسحاب قطاعاتها من
ضربات محتمله لكتائب المقاومه وسرايا
القسام ولكن الشمال مشتعل ليس فقط في
جباليا ايضا التفاح
والدرج لا يزال الاشتباك فيهما مستمرا
وايضا توصف الاشتباكات هناك بالعنيف قبل
نحو ساعتين من الان مراسله الجزيره عند
المنطقه او عند غلاف غزه عند المنطقه
الشرقيه المحاذيه لقطاع غزه افادت بان
رتلا وصف بالكبير من الاليات الاسرائيليه
كان يتجه الى هذه المنطقه او باتجاه هذه
المنطقه ليس من المعلوم بعد الى اي مدى
تمكن او ان كان قد توغل بالفاعل الى داخل
قطاع غزه او لا وهناك معلومات تقول بان
هذا الرتل قد لا يكون مخصصا فقط للمناطق
الشماليه ربما تكون ال الوجهه الرئيسيه
للرتل العسكري الاسرائيلي قد تسلك الطريق
عبر صلاح الدين وتنزل وال يعني ينتشر في
المنطقه الوسطى او باتجاه الجنوب الى
منطقه خان يونس ولكن قبل الانتقال الى
هاتين المنطقتين هناك نقطه يجب ان نشير
اليها بان القوات الاسرائيليه قبل ايام
اعلنت الانسحاب خلال ال 48 ساعه عدنا ونرى
ما كانت تصفه انذاك اسرائيل بانها توغلات
محدوده بعمليات سريعه تنفذها قوات خاصه
اليوم هناك عده تمركزات في احياء عند تخوم
بعض الاحياء حتى تلك التي لم تشهد حتى
الان اشتباكات على الاقل اليوم في الشيخ
رضوان هناك افادات بوجود بضعه اسرائيليه
وايضا تمركز للقناصه ويقومون باستهداف
المدنيين في حال رصد اي مدني يتوجه او
يتحرك في منطقه الشيخ رضوان والمناطق
المحيطه التوام وايضا العطاطه المنطقه
الوسطى قد تكون الاقل حده من حيث
الاشتباكات والقصف اليوم وما زالت ال
الجبهه ثابته عند نقطتين البريج والمغازي
ولكن في الجنوب هناك اشتباكات عنيفه جدا
القوات الاسرائيليه لا تزال تحاول التوغل
الى داخل مدينه خان يونس سمعت اصوات
انفجارات عنيفه جدا كتائب القسام استهدفت
عده اليات اسرائيليه وايضا تقول انها تخوض
اشتباكات عنيفه وضريه الى الشرق من مدينه
خانيونس والجنوب كان على مدى الاسابيع
القليله الماضيه المنطقه الاكثر عنفا من
حيث تركز الاشتباكات والاستهداف ولكن
للتعرف اكثر على وقراءه اوضح حول مشريات
الامور الميدانيه نعود اليك ميال شكرا
جزيلا لك سلام اذا لواء فايز سنبدا كما
بدانا مع سلام جباليه تحديدا وقبل ان نقرا
في الخارطه التفاعليه وما اوردته سلام
لنشاهد هذا الفيديو لعمليات اشتباك وفي
ذات الوقت ايضا قصف جوي من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على منطقه جبال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تحديدا
[موسيقى]
اذا نستمع بوضوح لاصوات القصف وجود تحليق
للطيران وكذلك عمليه الاشتباكات التي
شاهدناها في بدايه الفيديو والتي تظهر
استهداف اليه عسكريه اسرائيليه نريد ان
نفهم ما يجري في جباليا بالنظر لاننا
نتحدث عن عوده الزخم في هذه المنطقه عقب
قرارات الانسحاب التي تمت في شمال القطاع
والحديث عن التقنين والقدره على تفكيك
قدرات حماس هناك يعني رغم كل ما قيل كان
هناك تصريح لابد ان نتوقف عن يعني تجاوز
في دلالاته
ومؤشراته حديث نتنياهو وحديث وزير الدفاع
وغير رئيس الاركان هاليفي ماذا
قال
قال استطيع
حماس في ظل التحول الى المرحله الثالثه ان
تعيد بناء تنظيمها
القتالي مما قد يجبرنا الى شن عمليه جديده
وها هي البدايه اتضحت منذ 48 ساعه كنا
نتحدث عن التفاح والدرج ودخلت قوه بحجم
كتيبه دروع مدعمه بكتيبه من ناحال مدعمه
بسريه مدفعيه سريه مدفعيه مدعمه بجهد
هندسي وهذه قوه كبيره تعتبر لواء ناقص
عندما اتحدث عن هذا الحجم
وبالتالي كان الاقتتال لمده القتال لمده
48 ساعه في هذا اليوم بدا القتال في
المنطقه الاخرى لا توجد معلومات دقيقه
وواضحه نقدمها حول حجم هذه القوه وما وهل
هي القوه التي قاتلت في الدرج
والتفاح تعثرت فانع طفت باتجاه الجنوب
الشرقي من جباليا ام هي قوه جديده لغايه
الان ننتظر ايه تصريحات او ايه اخبار
عاجله تستطيع لكن دعيني اقول ان مدينه
القاطع الشمالي القاطع الشمالي من الطريق
عش الى السياج الان مشتعل ولكن بايقاع
مختلف الشيخ رضوان قناصين في منطقه التوام
ابراج المخابرات هناك توغل لكن يبقى دون
الوضع الذي كان سائدا سابقا قبل ان ننتقل
الى فيديو اخر على الاقل ليس لدينا
معلومات كما ذكرت عن حجم القوه العسكريه
الموجوده الان ولكن لدينا هذا الفيديو
الذي يظهر في ذات اللحظه اصوات الاشتباكات
مع اصوات الغارات
الجويه هناك عمليه رئيسيه انا قلت لك في
الدرج والتفاح كانت بحجم لواء ناقص انا
عندما اتحدث عن لواء ناقص تتحدث عن عمليه
رئيسيه هذه العمليه مسنده بنيران المدفعيه
والنيران الصاروخيه ونيران الجو وطائرات
ال العموديه وطائرات الكواب كابتور اذا
نحن نتحدث عن معركه لا اتحدث يعني في
البدايه كنا نتحدث عن عمليه دخول الانجاز
هدف مؤطر زمانا مكانا نوعا لا عمليه اول
امس كانت اكبر من ذلك وكانت توشي
كاشاريل كنا لم نتحدث بذلك قلنا قد يكون
عملا لتحقيق هدف ما اليوم تم تعزيز ذلك
العمل بعمل اخر مقارب من حيث الشده وهو في
منطقه جنوب شرق جباليا اذا هذا مؤشر ان ما
تحدث به رئيس الاركان هاليفي قبل حوالي
عده ايام قد بدا اسقاطه على ارض الواقع
فيديو القسام الذي عرضناه قبل قليل نعود
اليه الان وهنا تساؤل حول ان نشاهد ذات
التكتيكات من قبل المقاومه في عدد العناصر
التي تستهدف الاليات العسكريه الاشتباك من
المسافه صفر ومع ذلك لا يزال قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لا تستطيع التعامل مع
هذه التكتيكات يعني هو من الصعوبه بما كان
تتعامل معها التكتيكات من حيث من حيث
التطبيق الحرفي
اختلفت الان هذه منطقه اطراف مناطق بنيه
منطقه
زراعيه شاهدنا في الفيلم شخصيا الان ماذا
لاحظنا على الفيلم الفيلم لم يوضح الهدف
بالضبط وانما اعطانا رسم تصوري هذا هذا
الشكل لا ينسجم مع النمر ولا مع الميركافا
هذا ينسجم مع اليه الهمر وهي اليه لنقل
الجنود ولديها تصفيح خفيف قياسا مع الاخرى
وتسليح خفيف الهدف الاخر اتوقع ان يكون
عربه النمر لكن الصوره غير واضحه لكن
المقاربه كما قلت بالامس الان مسافه
التدخل تبدا قالها ب ميكانزم مختلف
البدايه هي انا تحدثت عن الذئاب المنفرده
صحيح
تعمل ب مقاربه النار والحركه المستمره
تعمل كعيون استخباراتيه واستطلاع هي تقاتل
قد تكون شخص او اثنين او لغايه ثلاث الان
هذه تكون منتشره ليست مجموعه او مجموعتين
مجموعه يتم توزيعها على طرق الاقتراب من
اجل اجبار قوات العدو ان تته ان تتجه باتخ
باتجاه هي مناطق تقتيل الان اذا تجاوزت
تكون معركه الصد فيديو اخر هذه المره
لسرايا القدس عمليه قنص جندي هذا الفيديو
من مدينه غزه تحديدا جنوب مدينه غزه شمال
قطاع غزه ان شااهد فيه اذا ايضا تقنيات
استهداف وقنص لجندي اسرائيل نعم هذه
البندقيه القنص تشبه الغول قد لا تكون
الغول انما هي مشابهه
ل بندق الغول الان هو
فتح فتحه في الجدار ويراقب وق القنص كذلك
قوات العدو الان تمارس عمليات القنس في
الشيخ رضوان فعمليات القنس المتبادل هي
موجوده يعني وبالتالي الان هو وضع السلاح
بفتحه من الجدار ويرصد ويراقب ويؤدي مهمته
وهذه جزء ما الذي يفسر ان جيش الاحتلال
حتى الان رغم مرور اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر لا
يستطيع التعامل مع قدرات حماس التي فيها
شيء من التكرار في اكثر من
مشهد لا يمكن لا يمكن له ان يتعامل بصوره
ناجحه مع كل الحالات الظروف متغيره يعني
لا يمكن اسقاط حدث قبل اسبوع على اسقاط
على حدث الان لا يوجد تماثل الان في بعدين
مختلفات الاطار الزماني والمكاني عند
اختلاف الاطار الزماني والمكاني حتى عبر
الاحداث التاريخيه لا يمكن للاحداث ان
تتماثل لهذا السبب لا بد من خداع شكرا
جزيلا لك لواء فايز الدويري